my next guest has gone from concerned
parent like many of you to legal
activists
not only confronting the woke teachers
in his district but taking it one step
further ian pryor looked into the school
district in his hometown
loudoun county virginia and got his
hands on some of their internal
documents
including part of a presentation
delivered by the loudoun county
equity director now it's hard to read
the fine print
but it's essentially a tool to help
brainwash teachers
into believing that white christians are
privileged
so everyone else is of course by default
oppressed
ian pryor the father who uncovered these
documents joins me now ian thank you so
much i've heard a lot about you i've
seen a great deal of your work
you also started up a website where
people
can chime in with the things that are
helping that are happening in their
district
when it comes to critical race theory
tell me what started all of this off for
you
well you know this really started off in
march when there was a group of
folks in a private facebook group
including six school board members
that were calling for targeting parents
for speaking out against critical race
theory
and that you know that really motivated
people across ideological lines
um you know really everybody to figure
out what was going on in our schools why
have we created a culture of
bullying in our schools in our community
that is affecting parents it's affecting
students and it's really sort of tearing
the community apart so you know we
started doing our due diligence
there's a lot of people out here that
are sending foias to loudoun county
public schools
uncovering all these documents that that
really show the divisive nature of
what they're trying to indoctrinate our
teachers with and then what our teachers
would then
indoctrinate our kids with and it is
really just appalling stuff
see that's important and now you're a
lawyer so and you've done some of this
using foias but at the same the freedom
of information act requests
but at the same time that you make a
very good point you know this is the
teachers
unions that seem to be moving this and
not every teacher we've seen teachers
push back and leave
and go public and and many are as
shocked as we are
but a lot of this material is in fact
to indoctrinate the adults to continue
because many
adults are thinking why are we doing
this to children and especially keeping
classrooms closed
other teachers are thinking this is
crazy as well so are you finding
that teachers are supporting you in this
as you go through this in your community
absolutely
absolutely so we set up a political
action committee fightforschools.com
where
you know we're getting all kinds of tips
every day a lot of the tips come from
parents
but a lot of it comes from teachers
teachers are fed up with having to
go through this these brainwashing
sessions and they just don't want to
teach the kids this stuff but here's the
thing they are petrified
to come out and speak out because they
fear repercussions from
the union system from the district
everybody
yeah i mean this is where then they'll
be branded and you can't get hired
elsewhere
right i mean then it then it's a matter
of like where do you go you know you
you're committed to your kids you've got
these school boards and even in san
francisco
they're they're recalling three members
of the of the school board up there
they would recall all of them but
they're not in the right you know
timeline of being able to do so
is the is that something you're looking
for so in addition to gathering
information
what do you hope is going to come from
this where do you want this to go
sure so it's really investigate
communicate and activate
and so we've been doing the
investigation with foias we've been
doing the investigation with
you know talking to teachers talking to
parents and then we communicate it we
get
out there we shine the spotlight of
accountability on the school board on
the system and then as far as activating
that's why we set up fightforschools.com
so that we can then engage in a recall
election uh in a recall petition to get
these six school board members off the
school board i mean they were in a
private facebook group
uh room where crimes were being
suggested and they did
absolutely nothing well ian you you're
an example of someone who's been
radicalized because of what has been
going on
congratulations sir and uh thank you
very much for joining us a very good
example of taking control of your
community thanks for joining us now
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else